but i wanted to get your take on
six nine
and
you know recently
whack because whack on my show said that
he didn't feel like six nine was a
snitch he said he felt like he was a
civilian who told the truth he's lying
she's all six knives a snitch so i
wanted to kind of get your take cause i
know you and i have had a discussion
about the snitch [ __ ] and it's
essentially
you know what do you define as that
okay so
the
the flaw in wax
discussion with that is he's a civilian
right so
on the west coast being a civilian means
i guess in theory you're not a part of a
gang you're not a part of the army the
infantry whatever that is right based
off of the real world
but everywhere else that's a rooted in
criminal like snitching has nothing to
do with gang banging snitching is rooted
in being a criminal you know omertha and
all these codes go back
before crips and bloods or any gangs of
black culture existed in this country
not snitching is a thing in criminality
like there no criminal will respect him
no criminal period will respect him and
i just think whack's not a criminal
yet what he's saying is obviously not
true he knows
that boy is a rat
that boy is a rad you know he's a rat
it's only you're not a rat if you're not
a criminal like if i did something to
somebody that's that's not a criminal
that's what they're supposed to do
inform the police if you do something to
a criminal he's not supposed to we all
know this
so because wax argument is rooted in
whether or not 69 is a gang member he
was a convicted pervert he was a drug
dealer before he ever met the gang
so you're saying
i mean and i i don't disagree with you
that the snitch
stigma or the snitch definition what
what makes someone a snitch is not
rooted in gang banging no it's not
rooted in whether or not you're a [ __ ]
or a blood or whatever it's rooted in
being a criminal world yeah and he's a
committed criminal he's devoted to the
the lifestyle of being a criminal he
just told it's nothing
man that spin is is a good spin for the
average you know i'm saying the average
fan out there you know what i mean it's
a great spin for them but if you really
in the life man he's a rat he know he a
rat